Heys there all right are there fights on
yeah you can just say these nuts in your
mouth
no no hey we went from being gay to you
being aggressive
yeah dude [ __ ] ain't gotcha huh yeah
Northman fired me up and you not knowing
Ricky Moore you really pissed me off
I don't know man come on I got to watch
it now this is this why do the podcast
um there's yeah I'll stroll dream and
Rosen strip Rosen struck do you know who
Rosen's true kids who he's a beast
I'm sure big huge guy for this man was
someone's celebrating I don't know I
heard somebody like scream it's tough to
tell psyche a murder or celebration
[Applause]
Joshua and yeah that's a big light
that's what I'm yeah that's I can't
someone sent me a thing Joshua
apparently got knocked out in training
again what he did who knows if it's just
the rumor mill and people are just
trying to get conspiracies going but and
then in the open workout for the media
injuries is doing work on this bag and
Joshua's just shadow boxing so
everyone's like big fight for Joshua
he's making 75 million it's kind of like
the biggest fight for Joshua your break
because he's my ride up right off to the
sunset and if he doesn't win there's
like chariklo to money yeah I think he
jumps down a bunch of gold coins in
England I wonder if he has sex with
girls I don't think they like him at all
he's not attractive look at that look at
that size difference Josh was at your
life fitter this done
he's slender guys lost some weight hmm
yeah that's a big one for him though man
had a man I know I know
but you know you know watch it they
can't wait call up [ __ ] Stallone see
if you can [ __ ] might be there well
it's Stallone and the boys might have
been Mike let's see what's up dude could
be could be that I was invited already
if the boys are famous people uh how
much taller how tall is Joshua and how
tall his release is actually pretty tall
he's short fat he's actually tall duh
well I mean Paris justice
for I think Joshua I survived
no no Wilder six seven sweet seven six
eight three six Fijian so
Wilders so really that my kind of snappy
Daenerys is 5:11 oh yeah
I would assume six six he's about six
five and then you know Wilders legit six
seven inch six eight fury six eight the
huge is so big yard Fury was even six
nine we've stood next to them so huge
you have yeah they're huge be interests
he yeah he definitely needs to win this
fight Louise looks like he's trimmed
down a little bit that's I think the
older one that's the old one he sees
thick mmmm Povetkin I think oh yeah so
you can watch with the bullet the tea I
can tell you is the TRT boys like what
are you talking about here the TRT boys
I'm sorry I don't know what you're
saying I do you know total up I get on
that ship right now yeah yeah yeah yeah
watch your tongue oh good what's gonna
happen what are you gonna do use some of
that boxing you've been doing
[Laughter]